Who believe that a red cow must be
sacrificed in order for the Jews to
progress plans to demolish the Al-Aqsa
mosque and build the fabled third temple
in its place. But hardline Israeli
group, the Temple Institute, have
already purchased and imported five red
Angus heifers from Texas. Doesn't that
ring a bell, guys? Now they said you've
come with the truth, then they distorted
it, even though Allah says in the Quran
it seemed like they were not going to.
Don't we all get happy when somebody
embraces Islam?
How many of us have the time to dedicate
to teaching them salah?
For the first time ever.
They are left in the dark without any
guidance. You are the reason for people
like Michael,
like Katrina, like Trisha, like me,
start to pray five times a day. That's
Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib, Isha. All due
to your donations. Brothers and sisters,
we only need 100 people to give 100
pounds. 100 pounds can help teach 10 to
30 people
learn how to pray salah and memorize
Surah Al-Fatiha for the first time ever.
Not only that, these reverts will be
teaching their families,
their wives, their daughters, and their
sons
to learn how to pray salah, all because
of your donations. The Prophet Muhammad,
peace be upon him,
said, "When you die, all your deeds come
to an end, except three. Ongoing
charity, beneficial knowledge, and a
righteous child who prays for you." Not
only is your donation an ongoing
charity, but also an ongoing beneficial
knowledge. Click the link in the
description below and donate now.
Peace be upon you and God's mercy and
blessings, brothers and sisters and dear
friends.
The Dajjal has been talked about many
times, and one of his signs will be that
when he will not be mentioned on the
minbar, and that is one of the signs
that the Dajjal will come. You don't
hear about him as much. Now, brothers
and sisters, very interestingly and
ironically, so funny, if you think about
it, that the Jews, they which I found
out that it's funny in the Torah and the
scriptures that they have to slaughter a
specific kind of cow. And why? Because
this cow is going to symbolize the
coming of their Messiah, i.e. for us,
the Dajjal. We're going to come to the
video which I talked about. Here's a
video which will dissect and make it
more clear for you, which I came across
and I thought I have to do a video of
this because this is so profound. It
shows how close we are to the day of
judgment, and not only that, I'm going
to tell you guys a verse in the Quran
which you're going to be like, "Oh my
gosh, that is exactly what Allah also
says in the Quran." Let's watch the
video for ourselves, inshallah, and
we're going to come. Could a Texas cow
start Armageddon in the Middle East in
April 2024? And what does this have to
do with Israel's war on Palestine's
Gaza? On the 100-day anniversary of
Israel's brutal assault on Gaza, Hamas
spokesman Abu Obaida released a video
explaining motivations behind the
group's incursion into Israel on October
7th. Alongside Israel's continued
occupation of Palestine, he also
mentioned the bringing of red cows into
the occupied Palestinian territories.
Obaida was referring to the plans of
numerous right-wing Israeli groups who
believe that a red cow must be
sacrificed in order for the Jews to
progress plans to demolish the Al-Aqsa
mosque and build the fabled third temple
in its place. It might sound like a
conspiracy theory, but hardline Israeli
group, the Temple Institute, have
already purchased and imported five red
Angus heifers from Texas at a cost of
$500,000. They have been grazing in a
kibbutz in the occupied West Bank since
2022, with reports that the sacrifice is
planned to take place as early as April
2024. The sacrifice of the red heifer
has its roots in the Torah and the
Talmud, and it is believed that the
ritual is necessary to purify the Jews
so that they can pray at the Al-Aqsa
compound. The sacrifice will reportedly
take place on a plot of land on the
Mount of Olives facing the Al-Aqsa
mosque. The cow must be completely red,
including its hooves, and must be around
3 years old at the time of sacrifice.
Following the sacrifice, the ashes of
the cow are due to be mixed with water
and used to purify selected Jewish
priests and their adherents. Since
occupying East Jerusalem in 1967,
right-wing Zionists have long sought to
build a third temple in place of the
Al-Aqsa mosque. While initially the goal
only of fringe groups such as the Temple
Institute, the plan has been
mainstreamed in recent years, with
groups of settlers regularly storming
the Muslim compound and attracting
support from numerous politicians and
commentators. Temple organizations have
even submitted blueprints for the
construction of the temple and prepared
the ornaments it will hold. Last year,
during the month of Ramadan, a Temple
Movement activist was arrested after he
and a group of Jewish extremists
attempted to bring a goat into the
Al-Aqsa compound for a ritual sacrifice.
The decades-long Israeli excavations
under the Al-Aqsa mosque have also been
condemned by international
archaeologists and denounced by numerous
authorities
So guys, you heard that for yourself.
Subhan Allah. What does that remind you
of? They are looking for a specific, you
know, cows, heifers, whatever you want
to call them for that matter, and that
it should be totally red color. It
should not have any defects. It should
be, uh, you know, perfect to the best of
ability. No yellow hair, no black hair,
etc. It all has to be red, and the
sacrifice has to happen in a specific
land which they've already bought that
has to be facing, um, the temple where
is uh, Masjid Al-Aqsa now, and they're
going to do that sacrifice. Doesn't that
ring a bell? Hmm. What does Surah
Baqarah say? What did Bani Israel, isn't
that interesting? What Allah ordered
Bani Israel to do. And it says, "And
remember when Moses said to his people,
Allah commands you to sacrifice a cow."
They replied, "Are you mocking us?"
Moses responded, "I seek refuge in Allah
from the foolish." They called upon him
and said, "Call upon your Lord to
clarify for us what type of cow it
should be." He replied, "Allah says that
it should be neither an old nor young,
but in between." Then they further
asked, as you guys know how it goes,
"Call upon your Lord." He said it should
be bright yellow cow, pleasant to see.
Then they asked again, then he said,
"And then Allah said, it should have
been used neither to till the soil nor
water the fields, wholesome and without
blemish." Doesn't that ring a bell,
guys? Now they said you've come with the
truth, then they distorted it, even
though Allah says in the Quran it seemed
like they were not going to. So subhan
Allah, how did Allah Allah like, you
know, this was revealed to the prophet,
peace be upon him, know about this stuff
about Bani Israel? And that's exactly
what's mentioned in their Talmud and in
their Torah that they have to do that.
Isn't that found? Now, let's talk about
the Jews, Zionists, and the Christians.
They are waiting for the Messiah to
come. Now, why? Now this is something
very, very interesting, guys. Subhan
Allah, just deep this for a second.
Brothers and sisters, the Messiah did
come. It was Jesus, peace be upon him.
We believe in this, his miraculous
birth, the miracles that he'd done. He
was the Messiah. They tried to kill him,
but Allah saved him from their hands.
Now, because they rejected the true
Messiah, which was Jesus, because of
their arrogance and because of their
attitude of killing the prophets, as you
can see, that's why the covenant was
taken from them and given to the
Muslims. Now, because of that, their
Messiah is going to be who? Who do you
think their Messiah is going to be? Who
do you think they are preparing this
for? Trying to destroy Al-Aqsa so they
can build their third temple. What? Who
is it? It's the Dajjal. They are going
to follow the Antichrist, the Dajjal.
Okay. Now let's come to the Christians.
The Christians believe that God came
down as a man and done miracles, and you
know, so they believe in this concept
that God can be a man, he can come down,
claim to be divine, and do miracles.
Interesting. What's the Dajjal going to
do? Hmm. I can remember once a Christian
guy came to me and said, "Uh, Islam is a
Dajjal religion." I was like,
"Interesting, you know, that's very
ironic. You believe God is a man, done
miracles, there you believe that. Okay.
So, when the Dajjal comes, he's going to
be a man, he's going to do miracles,
he's going to claim to be divine. Hmm. I
wonder who will fall for that, Muslims
or the Christians? You guys will fall
for it." So this is why, brothers and
sisters, when the Messiah comes, and it
is so close, because they are now
literally preparing to build a third
temple. Now, is this going to happen or
not? Regardless, if it happens for us,
that's the reason why the Jews want to
do that, and the Christians are heavily
supporting them. Ironically, you know,
they are supporting that cause. The
beliefs of the Christians is when the
Messiah, when Jesus comes, what the Jews
are going to do, they're just saying,
"Yeah, let's just trigger it. Let it
happen." When Jesus comes, he's going to
slaughter the Jews, yes, that do not
believe in him. Can you imagine? So,
they're in both each other's demise. And
for us Muslims, when that happens, we
believe that the Antichrist, the Dajjal,
there is going to be their Messiah.
They're going to both fall for it. As
Muslims, may Allah protect us from,
inshallah. Of course there will be some
Muslims
that might fall for it as well, uh, his
fitna. But which shows us what? That we
will, inshallah, wait for the true
Messiah, which we believe, which is
Jesus, peace be upon him. He will truly
come, not claim to be divine. He will
come and rather kill the Dajjal. And
inshallah, inshallah, that day will come
where trees will be talking to Muslims,
inshallah. Yes, that day would come,
inshallah, brothers and sisters, that
when they would, inshallah, we would be
on the side of the true Messiah, Jesus,
peace be upon him, and be in his army
against the Dajjal and those Zionist
Jews, Christians who did not believe in
the Messiah. And because of that, and
what does Allah say in the Quran?
Everyone of the people of the book will
definitely believe in him before his
death, Jesus. And on the day of
judgment, Jesus will be a witness
against them. Brothers and sisters, we
are very, very close to the end of
times. Very, very, very close, subhan
Allah, to the end of times. Guys, all
I'm going to say is that, inshallah, may
Allah bless you guys. Look after
yourself, inshallah, and prepare for
your day of judgment. It's the day when
you die. Don't wait for that big day of
judgment. The Dajjal is on, it seems
like, for them doing this, etc. The
third temple being built, whatever that
for that matter, inshallah. May Allah
ruin their plans, but whatever is meant
to be is going to happen, inshallah, and
the Muslims are going to be victori-
victorious, inshallah. It is clear for
us. We've had so many of the prophecies
coming. It is clear for us. Let them do
it. Let them do their oppression. Like
Allah says in the Quran, they will cause
fitna in the land twice, and twice Allah
sent their servants that will,
inshallah, deal with the oppressors.
Till next time. Peace be upon you and
God's mercy and blessings. Peace be upon
you.